Debra is the gene brown professor of
anthropology and the director of the
Center for experimental anthropology
most experimental ethnography right at
the University of Pennsylvania and she's
also sort of Kufa faculty in women's
gender and sexuality studies except talk
about the running way around it and it's
gender sexuality and women's studies I
haven't figured out the significance of
the different order and universities but
I'm sure there's something anyway I want
to take up too much time with the formal
introduction
photo Caribbean Sea so the top tonight
is actually drawn from your new work
which is coming out in October the title
is political life in the wake of the
plantation sovereignty witnessing repair
and I just want to say again how
incredibly grateful I am for you to come
and share your new work with us it's a
privilege so please
[Applause]
hi good evening Thank You hazel and
Thank You hazel and Interpol for
inviting me to be part of this seminar
and to the students for hanging out
earlier today what I'm going to do today
is as hazel said talk to you a little
bit about my new book that's coming out
in October and I'm sort of going to give
it two in three parts I'm going to give
you a kind of theoretical framing I'm
going to give you a kind of historical
framing and then I'm going to give you a
kind of imaginative framing after that
and I'm not going to give you any
evidence I'm going to show you some
evidence but I'm not going to talk about
it so we could talk about it in the Q&A
if you wanted to and talk about the sort
of extra textual dimensions of this
project which actually did not start as
a written project it did start as a
visual a visual project so I always tell
my graduate students especially that
when you start a ph.d program you have
to make sure that the question you're
asking is the question that keeps you up
at night you know what is that what is
the thing that irritates you the most
and and for me the question that keeps
me up at night is what does it mean to
be human politically in the wake of the
plantation how have people confronted
the unpredictable after lives of
colonialism and slavery nationalism and
state formation in a way that performs
not only a material transformation but
also an effective transformation
what does sovereignty feel like these
questions are the ones that have been
haunting me over the last 13 years or so
during which I've been developing
archives of the relationships between
sovereignty and violence in Jamaica my
specific obsessions have had to do with
the temporal regimes to which
post-colonial sovereignty projects have
been tethered how these regimes have
conditioned the affective States through
which they're enacted and experienced
and how they've shaped the complex
relations between sovereignty and
subjectivity within a context whose
foundational realities are imperialism
colonization and plantation based
slavery I've been interested in what
Sylvia winter has identified as a
constitutive tension between the
dominant logic of the plantation and its
internal threat the often Millennial
spaces within which enslaved persons
made maintained a conception of
themselves as human rather than as
property it's this tension that would
ultimately shape the relationship
between the national and the popular
over struggles over sovereignty and it's
also this tension that becomes legible
by attending both to moments of
exceptional violence and to the realm of
everyday practice my current project
which is a collaboration between
psychologist Dan Bell and musician and
composer jr. GABA Wedderburn concerns
the so-called Tivoli incursion in West
Kingston Jamaica in 2010 during which
members of the police force and the army
attempted to apprehend Christopher
otoscope who had been ordered for
extradition to stand trial in the United
States on gun and drug running charges
and in the process they killed at least
75 civilians the project aims to bear
witness to these dynamics regarding
subjectivity violence and governance in
the kind of quiet and quotidian way that
Tina camp has identified as a modality
of refusal the quote nimble and
strategic practices that undermine the
categories of the dominant witnessing as
implied here is neither straightforward
nor
unmediated rather it's ambivalent and
relationally complex in our agenda
therefore has been to really juxtapose
archives assemblages of archives and
these archives are visual archives their
oral historical archives their colonial
archives are also post-colonial archives
and we want to bring them together in
order to think through the relations
that they bring into being among the
psychic material affective prophetic and
political dimensions of sovereignty and
the broader historical and geopolitical
entanglements these relations make
visible and we also want to pull them
together in order to think through what
are the possibilities that they generate
for a redefinition of human recognition
so the form of witnessing that interests
me is one that I'm calling witnessing
2.0 and this is not the witnessing of
human rights organizations or of public
tribunals like Truth and Reconciliation
commissions which are limited in and
through their relationships to the
categories through which they're
mobilized such as Human Rights and
Reconciliation witnessing 2.0 is instead
closer to the form of bearing witness
described by Barbie Salazar in which
witnessing is the moral practice that
involves assuming responsibility for
contemporary events this is what sue
Tate has referred to as bearing witness
distinguishing it from I witnessing by
emphasizing its affective dimensions
beyond visuality Tate argues quote that
bearing witness exceeds seeing and this
excess lies in what it means to perform
responsibility or what Avery Jordan has
elaborated as response-ability
witnessing 2.0 is the kind of Co
performative witnessing for which Dwight
Conquer good a performance study scholar
consistently advocated this is a commit
a commitment to in so uni Madison's
words shared temporality bodies on the
line soundscapes of power dialogic inter
animation political action
matters of the heart witnessing 2.0
emerges through the development of
effective archives in order to reveal
the ways that we maintain the
conjunctures of power within which we
live as well as how the technologies
through which we witnessed potentially
exceed these conjunctures if therefore
offers us windows into what walter
Binyamin called the tiny spark of
contingency that might produce something
unexpected and that might redefine the
human outside of modernist binaries
witnessing 2.0 this makes visible how
effects operate in multiple
temporalities and across levels of
consciousness it's a practice of
recognition and love that destabilizes
the boundaries between self and although
knowing and feeling complicity and
accountability and one that potentially
reformulates the ground of the human
itself new world plantations it has been
extensively argued provided the basis
for modern social and economic
Arrangements in the Western Hemisphere
and beyond
contemporary claims and complaints
regarding humanists in the Caribbean are
therefore being made within a modernity
generated through the movement of Europe
with Africa conscripted toward the
Americas and the establishment of new
forms of genocide or violence as the
basis of a changing trans nationalist
transnational capitalist political
economy mercantilism inaugurated
material religious political
philosophical of scientific and
ideological processes that indelibly
linked the new world and the old in a
common project of redefining modern
humanity in racial terms the settling of
the new world also saw the twin
transformative processes of racial
fixing of diverse African peoples into
Negros and diverse indigenous new world
populations into India's and racial
flexibility which are the various
configurations of creolization
transculturation hybridity that emerged
these were processes that became instant
toosha lies through particular
extractive labour regimes and
constellations of citizenship that
excluded non-european groups the initial
racialized elaborations of what it means
to be human would be subsequently
mobilized to serve late 19th century
projects of indirect Imperial rule
throughout Africa and South Asia as well
as the emergent imperialist project of
the United States anti colonial and
nationalist projects sought to
interrogate critique and ultimately
revise these originally delineation of
the relationships between personhood
value and political legibility through
the development of new forms of
community cultural consciousness if not
always substantially new economic
arrangements indeed the elaboration of
continuity is between Imperial and
nationalist modalities of governance has
been a critical focus of scholars of
empire across the disciplines including
attention in the case of new world
societies to the ongoing forms of
violence that have been enacted against
black bodies modern liberal democratic
political arrangements have been
designed to hide these ontological
processes they've disguised the
dehumanization of foundational racism
through the conceptual framework of
perfectibility many anthropologists have
argued as much and while these
oftentimes brilliant analyses have
yielded trenchant critiques of the
diverse vectors of subjectification i've
also felt that they have stopped
sometimes stopped just short of the more
sensory dimensions of sovereignty and
have therefore left us unable to answer
other also pertinent questions this is
in part because much of this work
inspired by Foucault and Agamben often
fails to take into account what alex way
leah has called racializing assemblages
and to see those as foundational rather
than incidental to modern delineations
of humans not quite humans and nonhumans
what analyses of bear life seem to
disavow is that race always prefigures
notions of what it means to be a human
and potentially a citizen and thus also
what it feels like to be a problem
especially once political normativity is
marked by a liberal rights oriented
participatory democracy so this force is
a return to my original question within
this context what has it meant to be a
human capable of acting politically in
and on the world if we agree that
sovereignty is best understood as
dynamic practice and that therefore
there's no static or unitary
constellation to which it refers then we
must think of it as performed and as
embodied as constituted both from below
as it were and from above as performance
sovereignty is also a mode of address
and this requires acknowledgment from an
audience for whom the performance must
be legible and if all social projects
that are not forcefully imposed must be
effective in order to be effective as
will Mazzarella has argued then our
ethnographic attention has to be attuned
to the production reception and
circulation of these effective fields
focusing ethnographically on the
relation between effect and sovereignty
offers a number of affordances the first
of which has to do with the emergence of
the body onto the stage of critical
thinking not just as the raw material of
governance and management but also as a
way of knowing both publicly and
intimately this body is not private but
instead is social relational and
historical and it's unconscious is also
therefore fully historical and
culturally situated exploring the
constitution of the political subject
not primarily through nationalism nor
through state and extra state driven
processes of subjectification but
through the cultivation of embodied
effects that are shaped by the
particular temporal conjunctures in
which they emerge this enables us to
interrogate the ways political effects
can transcend the context of their
emergence allowing them to appear and
resurface unpredictably it
unbind sovereignty not only from
territory and therefore from the
political centrality of the
nation-states but also from teleology
zuv linear progressive time what an
effective approach to sovereignty gives
us then is a better sense of what
Donnell and Rutherford has called quote
the atmospherics of an age the
non-ideological dimensions of hailing
and aspects of relation that arrive
without explicitly calling attention to
themselves creating a sensibility of
community that disturbs both the spatial
and temporal dimensions of the
nation-state through the particular
forms of mediation that bring them into
being these atmospherics are grounded in
particular historical materiality x'
they're generated through particular
technologies and they produce temporally
specific expressions with different
effects in different periods so in
thinking through how the Tivoli
incursion came to be possible how the
conditions could have been created in
which it would be thinkable that the
military forces of the state could kill
so many people with relative impunity
we've been cultivating an archive of
affect this is Gale walls freezing one
that she mobilizes in order to
understand the role of the late 60s and
early 70s television variety shows soul
as both reflecting a connect reflecting
contemporary realities and embodying
dreams for a blackest beautiful future
archiving for her is not oriented toward
the past and its preservation but is
instead intended to elaborate new
possibilities for social and political
relations relations that in the case
she's investigating are generated
through popular cultural expression but
that we have explored through collecting
images sounds and narratives of state
violence
Nadia Ellis has called this elaboration
of possibility improvisation an embodied
affective register through which African
diasporic people enact survival under
conditions of unpredictability and
multiple forms of sovereign violence an
archive of
effect is not quite a counter archive or
perhaps it would be more accurate to
suggest that it's not beholden to the
Nationalists and masculinist discursive
frames that often contextualize counter
archives those documentation practices
and social movements that have taken the
space of the nation-state as there as
their primary mobilizing rubric have
accomplished many critical goals but
have ultimately failed to reorient our
conceptualization of social and
historical processes outside the domain
of the cultural and our visions of the
political outside the space of the
liberal hence the persistence of the
culture of violence and culture of
poverty tropes and the the patterns of
exclusion that characterized the
colonial period an archive of effect
instead opens a space of potentiality
one that might catalyze new
possibilities for seeing connections
previously taken for granted for
ordering our ontological x' our
ontological taking for granted like time
and space politics and justice and the
very terrain of humanism itself in
making this argument I'm not trying to
suggest that there's some romantic and
miraculous sphere of political action
outside significant 'victory processes
but I'm instead suggesting that the
unpredictability of effect and
subsequently its power lies in its
simultaneous operation at the cognitive
mediated level and at a more visceral
level we constitute ourselves through
political activity in the everyday both
at the level of consciousness and at the
level of embodiment assembling archives
of effect then should tell us something
about how the sphere of the political
has been imagined and felt at various
junctures and about the kinds of
politics that are possible at these
junctures it can help us to respond to
forms of racism that produced the
ideological terrain of the post contact
new world but also encourage us to renew
revive reconstruct and represent our
histories in order to rethink our
present our curves of affect because
they're nonlinear and thus
unobligated to the teleology zuv
liberalism can also shift the politics
of reparation away from discrete
discretely local and legally verifiable
events and toward the long and slow
processes undermining our ability to
forge social and political political
community together they can urge us to
be more skeptical about nationalist
narratives of perfectibility whereby we
triumph over past prejudices and in
Justices through a force of will and
commitment to moral right and instead
encourage us to train our vision more
pointedly to the transnational
geopolitical and socio-cultural spheres
and to the messiness of sovereignty at
different moments at the same time by
inspiring us to see and hear differently
archives of affect can help us to focus
on the everyday ways people innovate
life without constantly projecting today
today's struggle into a future
Redemption because they are in the end
technologies of deep recognition
archives of atha can also create a sense
of mutuality that not only exposes
complicity but also demands collective
accountability that's the theory section
my launching pad for these explorations
is of course the Caribbean and
specifically Jamaica where the pressing
question always seems to come back to
how the society came to be so saturated
with violence and what we can do to end
it in the Caribbean the history of
plantation development and the
transatlantic slave trade has meant that
there's been no straightforward
relationship between territoriality
nativeness and nationalist governance
more moreover in Jamaica as elsewhere in
the British West Indies the reckoning of
land rights norms regarding the
organization of political authority and
conflicts among subgroups developed not
in relation to original land use but in
relationship to a context at least prior
to the 19th century in which the planter
class wielded considerable political
influence within Parliament's
and absolute authority locally and in
which indigenous people have been
conceptually disappeared in Orlando
Patterson's classic text the sociology
of slavery he he argued that the primary
characteristic of Jamaican slave Society
was absenteeism and this was not true of
all West Indian societies this element
was central to the whole social order he
wrote and was in some way related to
almost every other aspect of the society
for Paterson the consequences of
absenteeism were legion it evacuated
Jamaican society from potential leaders
within all sectors and therefore
resulted in a legislative council
populated by individuals whose and this
is his words whose poverty and
inefficiency was a matter of public
notoriety who had no respect and no
influence and who therefore severely
diminished the character and efficacy of
public office and that's he's quoting
their governor Marquita Sligo
absenteeism prevented the development of
a proper educational system which meant
that even planters and their children
save the wealthiest remain semi-literate
and it quote led to a complete breakdown
of religion and morality among the
resident White's clergyman he points out
were some of the most profligate switch
then occasions a breakdown of the
institutions of marriage and the family
most of all absenteeism meant that the
majority of estate profits were
repatriated to England rather than
reinvested locally which was quote
disastrous for an economy so heavily
dependent on foreign supplies
absenteeism thus produced in his words a
loosely integrated society within which
there were no significant institutions
to create or reinforce laws furthermore
a patterson points out for more than a
hundred and twenty-five years after the
initial British colonization of the
island there were no comprehensive slave
codes and despite the passage of a slave
Act in 1696 the relationships between
masters and enslaved persons were
governed by customs rather than laws
this meant that while masters typically
enjoyed absolute legal power slaves were
also able to extract certain rights most
importantly in relation to the
cultivation of provision grounds which
became a much more expansive practice
than what had originally been legislated
by the slave acts both in 1696 and 1788
these grounds have typically been
understood as essential to the
production of foodstuffs to sell in the
market and therefore to the attainment
of of cash and you know at one point in
the late 17th early 18th century and
slaved persons actually were in control
of 25 percent of the cash circulating on
the island of Jamaica which is you know
property holding property so provision
grounds allow people to cultivate food
that they sell in the market from which
they receive cash they're also crucial
for the development and maintenance of
religious and social practices outside
the reach of the plantation customary
stewardship however of provision grounds
however also weakened slave resistance
to white power as trevor bernard has
reminded us this is his words now on the
one hand the tendency of slaves to
engage in capitalist market oriented
activity worked in the long run against
the logic of the plantation because it
reduced slaves dependence on the bounty
of the master and thus reduced his
control over him on the other hand
private property and market exchange
fractured slave communities disputes
over property and property related
crimes open opened fissures within slave
ranks confronting attacks on slave
property rights from outside often
healed these fissures but it also often
weakened the black community as a whole
making this relation between autonomy
and co-optation even more complex as
Burnett's assertion that whites as the
state owners managers and overseers were
slaves only protection against the
preyde larceny of other slaves as a
result potential solidarities were
further stream
and this is Bernhard again when a thief
was from within a slave community slaves
could humiliate or ostracize the
violator of group norms but when a thief
came from outside the closed society of
the plantation slaves had little option
other than to turn to their masters who
alone had recourse to the law and the
authority to apprehend and punish slaves
wherever they came from White's here
embodied the law and slaves as property
had no inherent rights unto themselves
and therefore any legal action on their
behalf had to be undertaken by their
masters slaves on the other hand entered
into competitive arrangements with other
slaves as custodians of property though
they developed collective interests in
the preservation of their economic and
arguably socio-cultural resources this
quote communal solidarity was limited
and territorially defined and the
customary agreements masters entered
into with slaves ensured the smooth
functioning of the plantation system as
a whole I've argued elsewhere that we
could read in these dynamics the
beginnings of a system of patronage and
clientelism albeit an unstable one in
which political authority was not only
racialized but also tied to territory
rooted patterns of protection that
ultimately encouraged alliances between
the powerful and those they exploited
and undermined alliances between the
exploited themselves in an interview
with David Scott Orlando Patterson made
a similar claim arguing that quote
there's a clear pattern of continuity
between the instability of slavery and
the plantation belt that sometimes
permeated the peasant area and then fed
right into the urban slums indeed patron
clientelism would become the defining
characteristic of a political system
that features what have come to be known
in the contemporary period as Garrison's
in Jamaica a nexus of customary rights
related to land use and heritability and
forms of patronage and clients holistic
loyalty forged the ground on which and
mechanisms through which nationalist
claims developed in the twenty
century what I want to highlight here is
that just as the plantation was
foundational to modern economic
production and labor organization it was
this phenomenon that also shaped the
infrastructures practices and processes
of politics with in post-colonial new
world nation states in Jamaica the
political economy of modern citizenship
was by the mid 20th century defined
through participation in the trade union
movement this broad movement ultimately
became politicized via the formation of
oppositional political parties the
People's National Party the PNP and the
Jamaica Labour Party the GOP each
connected to a union the Trades Union
Congress and later the national workers
union and the Bustamonte industrial
trade union respectively from the
earliest moments conflicts between
unions were also conflicts regarding the
politicization of territory especially
in downtown Kingston and these conflicts
were often violent in response to a
question from political scientist
activist and politician trevor monroe
regarding street fighting during the
Union during union conflicts in the
1940s Richard Hart who is a much
celebrated leftist political organizer
remembered quote whole streets changed
the composition of tenants living in a
particular area because if you were a
PNP man you couldn't live in certain
areas since power in this context was
personalized ultimately grounded within
the charisma and patronage of one or
another leader allegiances to union
leaders and therefore to political
parties were generally understood to be
transmitted through the family community
and the workplace this solidified
divisions within the working class but
clients holistic that works were not
limited to those operating within the
domains of organized political party
activism with working-class Jamaicans
but also included those within the
fields of education business journalism
and Community Development these are
people who would trade information
skills and contacts with their account
parts in politics the hegemony of
colonial class relations and patterns of
leadership was thus secured in such a
way that working-class Jamaicans would
continue support of a basically
middle-class political order long after
the support would have appeared
unjustified on any calculation of social
returns beginning with universal adult
suffrage in 1944 and culminating with
independence in 1962 as government power
grew it became more centralized which
further eroded the ability of
working-class people to make decisions
that would improve their political
economic and social circumstances even
at the level of local government this
situation was exacerbated by an
intensification of partisanship in the
distribution of state resources while
this became a feature of politics in the
late 1940s it really only became
institutionalized with respect to labor
by the 50s and housing by the 60s the
distribution of seasonal farm work
tickets for example but was by 1955
known to operate on a partisan basis
consider the example documented by
Trevor Monroe have a woman who
registered for a job with the government
employment Employment Bureau and was
asked what constituency she lived in I
was told that I would have to be a
member of some PNP group before they
would help me find a job to make sure I
wouldn't lie to them they told me to get
a note from the chairman of whatever
group I joined and that this kind of
thing was party policy is evident from
the 1959 peoples National Party group
leaders training course pamphlet that
Monroe cites which laid out the Paula
the following policy see that PNP people
get work of every 10 make it six PNP and
four GLP and PNP hardcore workers should
be provided for by 1966 when the GOP was
in power and when some factions of the
US labor movement were pressuring a
crushing the American government to shut
down the farm work program this kind of
partisanship related to employment
continued in the guise of assisting farm
workers visa the u.s. unions
in a letter from Michael Manley who was
at that point the islands supervisor and
first vice-president of the NW to his
father Norman Manley who is the leader
of the Opposition at that time he
explained that quote they're a great
friend in the American labor movement
called Nixon rich had advised him that
he had convinced the US unions to
organize West Indian farm workers rather
than to advocate for their removal as a
result the younger man Lee proposed that
representatives from the NW meat PNP
recommended farm workers before they
departed for the United States in order
to quote put them in a frame of mind to
expect to be organized by
representatives of the American trade
union movement he added that the nwu and
the PNP executive agreed that their
policy was to cooperate with the afl-cio
and that they did not wish to quote
include the ministry of labor and the
bus Davonte industrial trade union in
such an exercise but would prefer to
help through the efforts of the nwu
their own union this correspondence
shows that political partisanship in
Jamaica also took on a transnational
dimension and was also entangled with
foreign institutional bodies of course
this has been true not only in relation
to labor organizing but also with
respect to the organization of Jamaica's
involvement in the international trades
in drugs and arms which though a feature
of political struggles during the 1960's
emerged more strongly in the 70s and 80s
by the 1967 elections patronage in terms
of housing and jobs was explicitly
wielded as a political weapon with
continued patronage dependent on
continued loyalty the partisan system's
most explicit manifestation was through
the construction of housing schemes that
were made available to people on the
basis of party membership these
government constructed properties came
to constitute 40 percent or more of
housing stock in downtown constituency's
the colonial government had been
involved in constructing these kinds of
housing schemes for for people and for
people who had certain political
allegiances but these were typically as
a result of natural disasters hurricanes
for example and the PNP also had had
proposed a kind of slum clearance
program in 1961 right before they lost
the elections moving into Independence
when Manley was meeting with Kennedy but
it really wasn't until after
independence under GOP leadership when
squatters were removed from Western
Kingston and when Tivoli Gardens was
constructed and this really solidified
the links between housing territory and
political party in 1963 930 families
comprising 3600 people were removed from
the foreshore Road area in western
Kingston and the destruction of their
dwellings began on the 2nd of October in
order to enable phase one of the Tivoli
Gardens scheme additional evictions
beginning in mid-february and continuing
continuing until mid July 1966 displaced
an additional 2,000 people and this all
led to the replacement of a kind of
left-leaning back a wall with phases 2 &
3 back a wall was the name of the
neighborhood prior to its destruction to
make way for phases 2 & 3 of Tivoli
Gardens by mid-august
political gang warfare had surged and in
October that Jamaica Labour Party
declared a state of emergency that
lasted until after the 1967 elections
following the completion of Tivoli
Gardens which remains with Denham town
the Jamaica Labour Party stronghold in
downtown Kingston the PNP government
constructed additional housing for its
own supporters
the garrison ization of downtown
Kingston was further reinforced by the
abandonment of downtown spaces by
Jamaican elites and middle-class
professionals contemporary Garrison's of
which Tivoli Gardens is considered the
most perfect example are this territory
rooted
magis voting communities where political
support is exchanged for contracts and
other social welfare benefits as in the
past these exchanges have been
institutionalized and even codified as
part of the general procedures for the
distribution of paid work and social
services among constituencies downtown
with the vote benefits Nexus mediated
through the relationship between a
legitimately elected politician and
local what we call dawn this
relationship between the politician and
the dawn has not been static it's become
it became part of a more general
ideological struggle in the 1970s and it
subsequently transformed with the
elaboration of the transnational trade
in cocaine and weapons and that
supplanted a sort of smaller trafficking
in ganja and so what happens in the 80s
with the huge influx of crack cocaine is
that the Dawn's gained power over the
legitimately elected politicians so the
shape of their relationship changes at
that point this is also what has
perpetuated a kind of permanent war in
which Kingston figures centrally as a
spatially racially and politically
polarized place both discursively and
symbolically and it's what also brings
the garrison Dons to the attention of
the US government what were thus made
legible with the tivoli incursion in
2010 were the various scales at which
and through which the garrison operates
in other words the garrison doesn't
merely denote a physical space it's not
just the actual location of Tivoli
Gardens and sort of the space of Tivoli
Gardens within the world but it also
evokes an affective disposition
encompassing the requirement the
requirement of submission to a set of
dictating norms and forms of violence
that include the suspension of critical
consciousness the simultaneous
denigration of blackness and its
celebration in popular culture the
violent policing of movements and the
needs
appeal to a leader for the provision of
basic requirements so again that should
remind you of what's happening on the
plantation in terms of patterns of
authority so this is why other
modalities of organizing political life
and social development like Rastafari
like Black Power like the people's
freedom movement are seen and subdued as
threats not only to Jamaican sovereignty
and us hegemony but also to the
worldview that positions black bodies as
the instruments of profit both economic
and political for others what undergirds
my arguments here is the assertion that
these contemporary manifestations of
garrison politics are grounded in a
system of political authority on sugar
states that are again oriented toward
loyalty to a powerful figure and
reliance upon that figure for work
benefits and protection there is in
other words a certain kind of global
historical prior Necedah tribute to
political organization in new world
societies one that has to do with the
infrastructures practices and processes
of politics with in post-colonial nation
states in which the racialized category
of blackness must be understood as
foundational to the experience of modern
sovereignty we would do well to remember
that in Jamaica and elsewhere the
consolidation of plantation based rather
than peasant based agriculture only
deepened with the penetration of the
United States in the late 19th century
while in Puerto Rico Cuba and the
Dominican Republic plantations heralded
an investment in sugar in Jamaica was
banana production that became more
vertically opah integrated into an
export oriented plantation system
monopolized by ultimately United Fruit
Company and despite the fact that the
banana industry actually has its origins
as a peasant
crop tensions regarding a deepening US
influence over the Jamaican economy
extended to the political realm after
the 1907 earthquake in Kingston in the
wake of which governor Swettenham was
recalled to Britain because he refused
the assistant
of a contingent of US Marines who had
arrived on a rescue mission by World War
two with the basis for destroyers
agreement and in its aftermath with the
establishment of the Anglo Caribbean
Commission the United States had a
significant foothold in Jamaican
economic political and socio-cultural
life and this foothold only deepened
throughout the 20th century and into the
21st with the militarization of drug
policy and the intensification of
migration after the 1965 Immigration
Naturalization Act the US was therefore
fundamental to the reorganization of
sovereignty in Jamaica after World War
Two and intelligence gathering and labor
mobilizing were the critical
institutional spheres of this
reorganization I'm mentioning this here
in order to give a sense of the
multiplicity of sovereignties in which
to make ins our imbricated and to which
Jamaicans have had to respond at
different times and in Tivoli Gardens
certainly there have been multiple
sovereignties at play and the different
scales at which they've operated
sometimes in collaboration and sometimes
not give us some windows into the
effective socio-political field through
which people have attempted to make life
alright that's a history so if we
concede that seizing state power is both
an act of self-determination and an act
of sovereign violence then we're able to
grasp the inherently contradictory
nature of revolution and we're in a
position to take seriously Mzee key
themes argument that quote the
post-colonial experience produces
violence then that in and of itself is
related to the processes of liberation
drawing from Anglophone Caribbean
scholarship attending to the relevance
of fun own Yin views of revolution to
the formerly British West Indian
countries theme explores the gendered
racialized in class dimensions of
Caribbean nationalisms our argument is
that within a configuration in which
quote middle class and professional men
came to assume power over the nation and
have maintained their dominance
over other weaker men and over women in
general the Caribbean state became the
agent of this subject position the
relationships between gendered class
kinship norms and nationalist
respectability have been discussed at
length but what's important here is
names contention that were full
personhood and citizenship remain in
question for black working-class
Jamaicans working-class men have been
criminalized
and singled out for exceptional
treatment by the Jamaican state violence
against poor Jamaicans has become
normalized as what she calls a feature
of elite consensus around the
establishment of a social order that
rendered poor blacks also demeaned the
violence that fame is pinpointing is not
only the violence of political parties
and the racialized patterns of
structural violence that have become
normative throughout the Americas but is
also in everyday violence that permeates
encounters with middle class people
agents of the state and each other
the garrison fourth aim is the extension
of this violence and it's a quote symbol
of conquest and specifically of middle
class dominance over the poor through
the party mechanism
Fannin's point about revolutionary
violence is that it turns the norms of
society on their head it purges colonial
degradation and allows for the
reclamation of personhood and the
realization of meaningful social and
economic transformation but what kind of
liberation could phenoms cleansing and
humanizing violence bring within this
context one in which the response to
alienation from the nationalist state
has been violence disorder and
indiscipline though not necessarily of
revolutionary nature
those are Mizuki's words theme points
out that for many scholars violence in
post-colonial Jamaica has been an act of
empowerment or a means to visibility
through their competition and
collaboration with the state in the use
of violence themed rights segments of
the urban poor become empowered violence
in this frame is a route to recognition
but one that has primarily been
expressed and received or rejected
through the very masculinism that
undergirds the post-colonial order can
this ultimately allow for the
development of new political social
economic and ethical logics themes
suggest that quote we need a new focus
on the meaning of liberation which seeks
to deconstruct a decolonization steeped
in men's desire to power and to
simultaneously transform the quote
institutions of alienation and
domination that became features of the
post-colonial State so here is a crux of
an important insight into why earlier
political or earlier models of political
liberation have been exhausted
if we must confront what David Scott has
argued over the past two decades is a
crisis in the coherence of the secular
modern project then how do we contend
with the limits of post-colonial
sovereignty and its flawed models for
social change how might we critique the
incompatibility of de coloniality and
liberalism without falling into what
Sylvia winter called simplistic easy
radicalism z' within anthropology the
critique of liberalism has tended to
Center on the liberalism of Locke conte
and other framers of the Enlightenment
oriented modern state institutions that
would ultimately come to operate through
a focus on private property market
relations and developmental ISM it has
not typically turned it's a critical
lens toward the romanticists strands of
liberalism perhaps because these are the
strands that are the more common fodder
for anthropological research the cargo
cults and millennial movements critical
of abstract rationalism and capitalist
modernity that we have striven to make
legible given configurations of
inequality while we've deconstructed the
utopia's envisioned through these
movements we have respected them even
sometimes rescuing them from the sense
that romanticism tends inescapably
toward fascism totalitarianism and
similarly reactionary programs a vibrant
tradition of anti-enlightenment
Romanticism however is one that's been
central to many successful social
transformation projects
including extremely conservative ones in
large measure because of the tendency
toward charismatic leadership which is
not of course unique to Germanic
traditions but also and possibly more so
because of the effective as opposed to
the rational secular force of its
movements the problem of revolution then
should be reformulated in terms of an
ongoing struggle between two versions of
liberal social change secular
rationalist versus romanticist or in
other words pragmatist versus poets in
this reformulations the power of
institutional transformation would
probably rest in the modern secular
liberal revolutionary framework and the
power of affective attachment would
probably stay with the Germanic
framework in both its exclusionary and
inclusive guises if aspects of
Romanticism have been central to the
contemporary rightward shifts throughout
the Americas in Europe they have also
undergirded powerful social movements
like Rastafari that have gone the
furthest to critique the liberal
capitalist status quo and the
progressive teleology zuv developmental
ISM why then have we not tended to
imagine our own revolutionary futures
through this lens my Khloe and Robert
Sayre have advocated for a
reconsideration of romanticism in
romanticism against the tide of
modernity they argue that the critical
force and clarity of Romanticism lies in
its exposure of quote the blindness of
the ideologies of progress the unthought
of bourgeois thought their argument is
that romanticism can be both
revolutionary and counter revolutionary
and undergirding movements with
radically discrepant ends what is common
to all however is a quote value on life
love hope freedom and joy as well as
creativity and a rejection of the
Enlightenment abstract rationalism as
well as stultifying reification defined
here as quote the dehumanization of
human life the transforming of human
relations into relations among things
and our objects this they see as having
a
company the move toward global
capitalism where most locate romanticism
as emerging in the wake of the French
Revolution as a result of
disillusionment with the bourgeoisie
that seized power Louie and Sarah track
it back to the early 18th century and an
emergent disillusionment with the spread
of capitalism they argue that in pushing
a critique of capitalist modernity the
romantic view constitutes modernity self
criticism throughout their texts they
chart a typology of Romanticism
differentiating between restitution
Eskin Servat 'iv fascistic resigned
reformist and revolutionary and/or
utopian romanticism Zweig for them would
include Jacobin democratic romanticism
and distinguishing further between the
english french and german varieties of
each so it's the last category of
romanticism that contains some
interesting bedfellows Marx and Engels
appear among the utopians as well as
Bucca and and Stalin EP Thompson and the
Franklin school Frankfurt School LOI and
Sarah also argued that surrealism was
the 20th century movement that most
brought the romantic aspiration to
reinvent the world to the peak of its
expression and we know that surrealism
also heavily influenced thinkers like ma
says air and the later Situationists
while Louie and sir do not tether their
grounding of romanticism in anti
capitalism to imperialism and the
colonization of the Americas at all if
we understand modernity as the ground
upon which our degradation as non or not
quite humans is realized then we should
be able to see the appeal and purchase
of an anti modern philosophy and
practice within settings characterized
by colonization and Plantation slavery
for Europeans romanticist nostalgia for
the past and the desire to recreate a
pre capitalist human community was often
reckoned through being harmoniously
connected with nature while this has
been a strand within new world post
plantation movements the desire for the
recognition of personhood
Romanticism critique of reification
would perhaps be it's more compelling
dimensions so in Jamaica we could define
the struggles for a revolutionary social
change as one between the progressive
left which is a formation that I would
take to include the various Marxist and
black power groups that came to occupy
the political landscape after universal
suffrage in 1944 but more stridently in
the late 1960s in the early 1970s so
that's the progressive left on one side
and the prophetic left a formation that
would encompass Rastafari but also
Ethiopian ISM and earlier redemptive
religious movements like bad word ISM as
well as kind of secular prophetic hybrid
movements like garveyism of course these
two formations especially during the
late 60s and early 70s did not exist
within a nationalist vacuum and were not
necessarily mutually exclusive at
particular moments and within particular
context there were significant points of
overlap and sometimes collaboration
between these two versions of social
transformation at other times there were
significant significant disconnects
moreover if the general difficulty of
revolution is not the breaking of the
old but the institutionalizing of the
new then the the difficulty of both
forms of revolution in the Caribbean and
the devastation attending their collapse
has to do with the position of the
region within a global political economy
economy increasingly dominated by the
United States and now also China for the
progressive left the bourgeois rights
achieved through liberal revolutions are
important meaningful and deserving of
more profound elaboration through the
strong and slow boring of hard boards as
Weber once famously defined politics
this is an approach that criticizes the
present while calling on modernity to
surpass itself and it's one that works
from the messy and difficult here and
now rather than envisioning a utopian
past or future it attempts to form
alliances between the positions of
actually existing people with their
actually existing flaws in order to
produce actually existing change through
the seizure of the state for them
romanticist movements are important but
cannot ultimately play a leading role on
the stage of revolution however within
our actually existing context I would
actually argue that it's romanticists
movements that have consistently
produced meaningful and lasting
transformations in people's
understandings of the world and their
place in it and therefore of their
internal worlds and inter subjective
relations in part because they do not
respect the boundaries of the
territorial state theorizing sovereignty
in relation to questions of effect
therefore forces us to generate more
complex accounts of the historical and
social relations through which notions
and experiences of sovereignty are
produced experienced and circulated over
time and space it also encourages us to
more fully appreciate the complexity of
how visions of the present future and
social change are inhabited and
expressed in really complex and
sometimes contradictory ways let me
return to busy key themes claim that
corruption middle class dominance and
the criminalization of black
working-class men and women in Jamaica
can be dismantled only by displacing
men's desire for power from the center
of political thought and action while
they Burien conceptualizations of
politics and revolution do much to help
us take seriously the effect of states
that constitute notions of politics and
community it's true that they don't
necessarily move us outside of the
broader frames of masculinism neither as
we have seen does the secular
rationalism of the progressive left so
what theme is proposing is a kind of
feminist solution one that makes visible
other kinds of struggle and action
typically led by women that don't rely
on charismatic leadership that involve
collaboration among diverse stakeholders
and that aren't oriented toward taking
control of the state and this is you
know her own program of research and
it's a really
important one what I want to propose is
another kind of feminist solution not as
an alternative but as a way to walk
alongside [ __ ] it's a solution that's
Gerrits grounded in witnessing 2.0 that
quotidian practice of watching listening
feeling that's relational and profoundly
inter subjective this solution is geared
toward one taking seriously embodied
effective ways of knowing in an effort
to to track the long term entanglements
that have produced and sustained the
binaries structuring our modern world so
that we find ways to three undo
dualistic modalities of thinking and
acting in order to for generate
meaningful forms of repair I ultimately
argue that this repair must be generated
through the real love of deep
recognition but that is the subject of
another talk for now let me conclude by
stating that thinking sovereignty
through effect speaks to the ethical
impulses of this project and the
questions that originally framed it how
are we complicit in the perpetuation of
sovereign violence and what might real
liberation feel like thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
do you mind if I start
yeah I was very interested in the
different scales in the talk but we were
also getting visuals down what we were
seeing that you weren't you were maybe
implicitly but not explicitly
referencing yeah but so from the sort of
you know the surveillance scales to the
streets but we end with the target on
this woman and so in your feminist
analysis are you are you imagining that
this this is the site of the hope and
the movement for change because so many
of the structures you've been talking
about were masculist
so it's this area of the effect and the
feeling going to be mobilized do you
think primarily by women
yeah at a local though I mean I'm just
wondering because it's actually a quite
a depressing visual ending with the time
I mean yeah no I just wondered where it
actually leaves mm-hmm you're in
relation to your question of hope where
a women in that in terms of the battle
against these masculine as structures
yeah I wouldn't necessarily locate this
move I wouldn't I wouldn't do the
essentialist thing I'm not a that I'm
sure you know this is a gendered
expression effect but I think there are
two levels of things you know and one is
what Mizuki is doing you know and I
think it's super important which is if
we're always looking for social change
and revolution
at the level of these big movements or a
vanguard or a state or something then
we're missing all of the stuff that's
going on on the ground which tend to be
led by women you know because it's
attending to quotidian concerns and it's
you know the stories about politicians
taking over projects that women have
started on their own in their community
are legion you know oh well you know we
see that kids are not getting homework
time so let me leave the light on
outside my shop for a couple extra hours
every night and we'll make that homework
circle and then the politician comes
along sees that this is working takes it
over and then only members of that party
can like participate in that right or
various other things school school
breakfast school lunch whatever it is
you know it's so I think it is important
to look at these spaces that are not
oriented toward control of the state to
see what forms of change are happening
at the local community everyday kind of
level and how they're impacting people's
lives right what what visions they
reflect in terms of where people think
their sphere of influence is and what's
important to them in and those are going
to be different you know in different
spaces there's not one totalizing
revolution that's going to happen to
come along and change things for
everybody in the same way right so
that's one dimension of explicitly
political action that's important to
attend to but you know all that kind of
stuff can happen changes happen policy
happens but people's minds and their
hearts don't change and I think that's
that's what we see so even even in the
face of massive structural change people
hang on to old ideas and old feelings
and I think that's what I've been really
interested in how how people go through
an internal transformation that changes
the way they approach the world so I
mean
part of this kind of started when I was
working with this group called the
international peacemakers Association
which is a sort of the latter-day
development of the Claudius Henry
movement that something that sort of
happens in Kingston in the late 50s and
then there's this big scandal where the
state thinks that they're trying to you
know take over and then sell Jamaica to
Cuba and Fidel Castro and they found
this cache of arms and so they arrest
who they can arrest and charge Claudius
Henry with treason and assassinate his
son and two other accomplices in 1960
well Henry comes out of prison ten years
after he goes in and then reforms this
movement in a rural Jamaican rural kind
of central Jamaican parish and they
build this kind of they build a
community for themselves which is a
spiritual community but it's also a
community that's about economic
self-determination so every cement block
that is used to build every house they
have made with their own hands every
tile every piece of land that's grazing
they have tilled you know so Walter
Rodney becomes interested in this
community but he's really only into the
economic self-determination part and
thinks all the spiritual stuff is
nonsense
but at any rate you know the thing fails
eventually it does you know so I've been
interested in what failure looks like
because of course it doesn't ever die
you know once when you talk to those
older or gentlemen who were involved
with him from the late 1950s the massive
transformation in worldview that their
participation in this movement
occasioned for them lives you know and
what they were able to build in this
community before everything kind of fell
apart like they felt differently about
themselves and they felt differently
about who they were in
world and what the police of Jamaica was
in the world and it like so moving you
know because you can feel it when
they're talking to you still today I
mean many of them have passed know since
I began interviewing them but but I
think you know youth in the community
also feel it but they don't necessarily
know why you know so every person
passing while you know I'm sitting and
talking to one of them on the veranda
they hail them up they you know and
they've not necessarily shared with them
their experience you know politically
but I think they can feel it you know
and I think that feelings circulates so
once you've had a transformation like
this of course it affects everybody with
whom you interact you know and they they
then could take it up without having
been involved in the original thing you
know and so I've been kind of interested
in that sort of effective circulation
and how those fields then multiply you
know and I think as a dancer you know I
would always feel that on stage you know
you're moving with people at some point
you transcend that scenario you know not
every night probably and you know
sometimes this is like oh god can I get
my body to do these things again you
know but but there are those moments
when it's more than the music it's more
than the group you just feel it you know
and I can't really articulate what that
feeling is but I know that it's moving
through me to other people you know and
it's that kind of thing that I'm
interested in because that is what
generates a different a different
relational field you know in which we
could transform our history in our
relationship and create something
different you know and and that has
meant moving outside of political
economy literature and thinking through
psychoanalysis you know and and thinking
about the ways people have tried to
imagine these kinds of interest
subjectivity as transformative and
outside of the cell father dyad and it's
you know
it's the radical a psychoanalyst you
know who are who are doing that in a
different way but so I you know is that
gendered I mean not necessarily but in
our society that domain has typically
been understood to be accessed more
regularly by women but I wouldn't put
too fine a point on that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was just curious how take
this understanding between sovereignty
and effect and in particular its kind of
performative dimension of sovereignty
they've mentioned the call that elicits
a kind of response with other
understandings of sovereignty in the
state in anthropology so like okay uh
thinking about the kind of you know
roundup radiation almost of the state
through quotidian practices how you
understand these things together
the second question was and you can
deflect this because you said it was the
subject of another talk well yeah just
we're deep wrecking what do you mean by
deep recognition which is like a very
evocative term and I was wondering if
there was a conceptual place at all for
democracy within this project and
whether it bears some relation to what
you were just talking about this kind of
altar in the field of relation yes
radical intersubjectivity that is
episodic the rare bear some resemblance
to what Sheldon Wolin
political fear is called fusion of
democracy these are moments of kind of
spontaneous coming together in the
creation these moments of the genuinely
political and so what and whether I mean
I mean it's I know that much but maybe
Rastafari political fighting practice is
a resource deterrent for that but I
would you know is just broadly carries
about democracy yeah well you'll have to
give me that reference because that
sounds interesting and perhaps more of a
peace with the kind of stuff I'm
thinking about then normal liberal
democratic theory would be so when you
say democracy like that that's what I'm
you know it's liberalism to me you know
or a particular conjuncture of how
liberalism has been sort of sedimented
here but I would be excited to hear to
learn about the fugitive democracy that
you mentioned in terms of recognition
that really the deep recognition the
love that really is the psychoanalytic
literature's right and you know phonon
talks about the failure of you know what
we might now call de Cluny ability
through the lack of recognition by one
is on the Iraq
not as an object and he sees he he sees
a broader form of recognition being
enacted through them which he gets at at
the very end of black skin white mass
but I've been sort of looking more at
like loving us and working through oh
thank you some of the feminists psycho
analysis theorists not necessarily
practitioners to think through those
kinds of issues and it ends up in sort
of the code the last chapter of the book
but it's you know it's an internal it's
an internal process right and therefore
difficult to measure by any of the sort
of modern methods that we would use to
think about change in consciousness and
change in action you know and I think
therefore deeply unsatisfying to a
normative political scientists or even
you know impatient revolutionaries you
know who really want to map
transformation in different terms and I
guess I'm just frustrated with that you
know and feel like it hasn't occasioned
the real change and even they're like
really left movements in the 70s in
Jamaica did not and we're not able to as
I said in class like we're all prisoners
of our own formation on some on some
level and the first one was Oh
sovereignty yeah I mean it's all part of
a piece right you know like how do we
come to cede ourselves in our daily
perambulations as subjects of the state
through these very small interactions
from the ground up but also you know
from the top-down when in how are we
hailed how you know I like I find myself
constantly having to
and myself to resist the hailing like
every time I like you know um on the
water or something outside Kingston
Harbour I have to stop myself from
singing a stupid folk song or you know
what I mean or identifying with that
moment and feeling one with the
landscape or whatever you know because I
feel like nationalism is really a
powerful powerful force especially like
a post-colonial nationalism you know and
I find it necessary to attempt to resist
it at every turn even as it also appeals
to me immensely
you know both through the kinds of
healings of sort of citizenship and
through the day-to-day kind of
interactions that support or challenge
you know those those citizenship claims
or claims to subjectivity in one way or
another so I mean I like Gupta's work a
lot I like Tom Hansen and Finn's
depakote who really do focus on
performativity an embodiment and process
I think that's the key is to think
sovereignty as process and project you
know not as something that exists you
know as like some bundle of thing you
know but as something that's ongoing
how you characterized or described
and there at any time
or even in the communities
well of course historically the church
you know has played both a progressive
and a conservative rule certainly a role
in all of the slave rebellions the
church the Christian Church the Anglican
Church and the nonconformist churches
Methodists Presbyterians etc the church
bought up you know properties and
distribute to them in smaller parcels to
members I'm not sure how to say this
without sounding anti church that you
know all all of those forms of progress
and liberation come in a cost to my mind
one then has to transform oneself one
has to espouse certain values one has to
practice and perform a certain kind of
respectability which for many was a
stretch you know and for many was
something they did in order to achieve
the land or to you know to to meet the
bargain you know in order to better
themselves as they saw was possible at
the time so that's great
within the community within Tivoli
actually there's one church that's
really untrusting I mean there are a
number of churches there are a million
churches in Jamaica of course people are
very religious in every kind of public
forum discussion yeah every public forum
you know I'm giving this lecture for the
National Library and they said okay so
we should have a member of the security
forces it was like
okay and so then we decided on somebody
actually know who's you know the head of
the now he's the head of the police
commission but he's very reasonable
interesting person who I know socially
so that will work then the second thing
is always we need somebody from the
church it's like why do we need yeah I
grew up in the church so but yeah you
know it's like a it's a very strong and
powerful part of many people's lives and
there's one church into the gardens that
has been very active and actually really
interesting in the way it has attempted
to develop leadership in the community
mostly women and youth and sort of
they're on some level sanctioned by the
dawn but the dawn mostly stays out of it
and that's sort of an arrangement that
anything would have to any institution
would have to have within that
particular space there's an
acknowledgement but there doesn't have
to be a constant interaction as is the
case in this particular church so they
have to walk a very fine line but you
know between allowing people to empower
themselves and not allowing that
empowerment to challenge the kind of
dominant system of authority in the
community so it's you know it's it's
complex I guess I would say there's a
woman key John Bloomfield who's done
some really interesting work on some of
the churches and their mission in Tivoli
Gardens and the ways that they have this
one pastor in particular has attempted
to destabilised on leadership while also
operating through it you know and I
think it's really difficult for them
it's a it's a complex dance
oh well Hazel's rights as always um you
know there are multiple scales we I mean
I'll tell you a little bit about how we
got the different images so all of the
surveillance staff came out of a US
drone that was overhead through the
operation that some members hi
high-ranking members of government
disavowed actually during the commission
of inquiry even the head of security and
defense was saying no there was no US
drone ever had in the prime minister had
to come on the stand and say yes in fact
you know I had asked for it but I
thought we were just going to get you
know satellite surveillance but then of
course the the you know attache and the
US Embassy releases the cables through
WikiLeaks that say no that the
government asked for a surveillance
plane with you know etc etc at any rate
so we got that because there was a
journalist who wrote a big expose on
what happened in The New Yorker match
Schwartz and Wendy Ann suggested that we
do something visually about Tivoli and I
was trying to put her off of that I
yeah one of my friends who's done a lot
of civil society works suggested you
know say Oh contact Matt because he was
living in the community you know because
it's such a closed community I couldn't
find anybody who had you know done any
NGO work or any tie that I could have
really developed you know in the way
that we had ties for about Friday you
know I just didn't think it would be
possible to kind of float into this
community we had never been in that has
been closed to outsiders and say oh
let's make a film you know so anyway she
put me in touch with Matt and he did a
he was working with a Yale Law Clinic
actually and and they did a FOIA request
for anything related to the operation
and then he got you know hours upon
hours upon hours of drone footage and
then he passed it on to to us you know
and so that's you know that bird's-eye
view which you know when we would come
back and forth having strong footage
together with people that we were
working with in the community to you
know ask them do you like the direction
we're going in here are you still
comfortable with what you said it's such
a cetera you know when they saw the
drone footage for the first time it was
quite shocking to them because you know
they're now seeing from you know
sometimes two miles overhead what they
had actually experienced like cowering
under somebody's dining room table for
three days you know what I mean so the
scale difference from their experience
and what they're able to see watching
the soldiers like scurry around like
ants and you know actually in some cases
corroborating things that they said at
the commission of inquiry you know we
always think about drones and
surveillance footage as negative you
know but in some cases that was actually
supporting things that they had said
during the commission of inquiry that
the lawyers were trying to disavow you
know so that's that then we did there's
the kind of contemporary landscape
images you know that kind of stuff
because we were really interested in the
material evidence of violence in the
landscape the stuff that people have to
pass by every day the broken windows
that are still in their houses years
later because they can't afford to fix
them what it looks like to live in a
wounded City you know in that way then
we did a photography workshop oh there's
all the archival footage of course and
then there's the oh those are actually
not soldiers on the roof those are gun
men in this case but there are also
images that look like soldiers on the
roof but the newspaper footage gives you
a different kind of history that if you
sort of were hip to it or you had enough
time to read a little bit of it it would
give you the history of political but
the development of political violence
during the 70s and the sort of you know
how it how it just grows throughout the
decade and then we did a sum of I took
some design students down they did a
photography workshop with these youth
and some of their pictures sorry
well you saw some of their pictures the
quick pictures that came by this
this tradition here is called Reviva and
it's one of the forms that really
emerged into the so and so this alright
so I wanted to juxtapose these two you
know of course because I'm a dancer but
also because it shows the continuity in
embodied movement forms between the
ritual practice and the popular practice
so in revival you know this is something
that really solidifies in the 1950s into
the well in what becomes Tivoli Gardens
in baka wall as a kind of rural practice
that gets re inscribed in an urban
location and you saw the revival table
you see the drummers they see the kind
of dance which is called thumping you
know but then here you have pasa pasa
which is the kind of weekly street dance
that became well known and which is
right on the edge of Tivoli Gardens and
it's one of the spaces that outsiders
could come to the community you know to
do the famous really worldwide so I
wanted to sort of also include those as
living archives you know living embodied
archives of how people have consistently
made life in conditions of violence and
then at the very end you see sometimes
still photographs and sometimes this is
just in the studio as we're you know
getting ready to record their narratives
of the people with whom we worked in the
community and some of this was about
showing not just suffering victims but
also people who are members of families
and communities and who are laughing and
smiling and also crying and also you
know grieving mourning and in a
relationship with us and with each other
so so anyway these are elements that
then became part of a film a 40 minute
documentary where you would hear their
narratives are some of them or parts of
them and also then of a more abstract
nonlinear piece in which their
narratives are not sort of for grounded
as total complete stories but we were
interested in juxtaposing them in ways
that we thought would for you know for
the audience for whom we were making and
it's would have some kind of response
where they might think about the ways
that these narratives implicate them in
maintaining the political status quo so
that's not you guys you know but that's
like a Jamaican middle class audience so
when we've showed the documentary in
community settings in Kingston people
were in it calm people were from the
communities come they get up afterwards
they tell their stories again they
highlight the parts that I edited out
you know or other people from
surrounding communities will get up and
tell their story of what happened to
them during you know this week in May
they'll talk about you know the legacies
of slavery and imperial though they
basically write the book you know that I
just wrote basically you know and they
talk about how we will never know the
true and lasting effects of events like
this because now it's almost ten years
and you know so kids who are eight nine
and ten at the time of the incursion who
talked about or whose parents talked
about how they can't hear a loud noise
without wetting themselves how they
don't sleep anymore or they you know
went down in school or whatever you know
you can't measure that trauma you know
and you can't you can't take a full
measurement of how that affects the ways
that they make decisions for their lives
now and I think that's that's where the
conversation usually ends up with people
in these kinds of grassroots settings
where we've been showing it as a way to
talk about political violence and the
legacies of political violence in
Jamaica middle class settings I'm not
sure yet we're showing it at the
University in March but but based on you
know what we've tried to do in a couple
diasporic settings you know people have
we all have our political biases you
know and if you were alive in the 70s we
all have our sides you know that we
cling to and it's very very difficult
for people to humanize people outside of
Tivoli Gardens or outside of the jlpt
humanize people in this community so on
some level especially for people who are
active lefty mobilizers and the 70s to
even listen to these stories as a
betrayal you know it's for us to have
attempted to humanize them you know is a
political betrayal in and of itself
because they're wedded to the project
and not they don't therefore see this as
as state violence that's wrong you know
that in fact the state should like
whatever your political sympathies the
state should not be able to go into a
community and kill people you know or
you know they're sure that they're lying
or that there's another motive or why
didn't we interview members of the
security forces why don't we have a more
balanced portrayal you know so those are
the kinds of questions that we've gotten
and you know we just have to say you
know that was not our aim our aim was
not to make a balanced portrayal this is
not a traditional documentary you know
this is to sort of implicate all of us
into this story
it's that answer that was a long and
rambly answer but I don't know if it
brings together
[Applause]
[Music]